all right so of course we have to start
today with joe biden selecting
california democratic senator kamala
harris to be his running mate yesterday
later in the day
uh speculation sort of building we were
supposed to hear around
august first august first came and went
august 8th came and went
the convention starts in just days so it
was time and we did hear that indeed
senator kamala harris is going to be joe
biden's running mate
this makes her the first woman of color
to ever
be a vp or presidential nominee although
as many of you know i don't particularly
focus on identity type stuff but it's
certainly relevant and i'm going to talk
about it
more obviously this pick
immediately set off a cascade of
criticism from some on the left and of
course the right immediately going into
all sorts of attacks on kamala harris's
character and joe biden's character
donald trump
saying uh horrible things about her
during yesterday's press briefing which
we're going to look at but that those
those are sort of details right the
monday morning quarterbacking
and the rest of it are are not where i
want to start
let's look at the pros and cons of
kamala harris first and i'm going to go
directly first to the worst of kamala
and work backwards from there
but before i do that there are people
who are writing to me and who i'm seeing
on twitter and other places saying this
is a terrible pick david this is
who could possibly be worse than kamala
harris any other person or at least this
person or that person would have been
better
every one of the supposed finalists had
problems and i think that it's important
at this point
not to um fallaciously imagine
that anybody who we might be able to
pick
out of a hat could have been better
because most of those people weren't
actually being considered the people
reasonably being considered
were by joe biden's own selection
narrowing a woman
increasingly pointing to a woman of
color although
joe biden never really said that but you
might remember when amy klobuchar
removed her name from consideration even
though it had already been removed due
to her association
um in in minneapolis related to
derek chavin uh the man who who killed
george floyd
amy klobuchar on her way out said it
should be a woman of color etc so
being able to say well what about this
person who was never even really up for
consideration that's not the way
politics works we might like it to work
that way but it doesn't
in terms of the people who seem to be
finalists if biden
goes with elizabeth warren according to
some that's a problem because elizabeth
warren is not
a person of color according to others
elizabeth warren would have been a
problem because she's
too liberal others would say well
elizabeth warren is a northeasterner
and that's not what joe biden needs
right now or whatever
biden picks susan rice it's pandering to
obama supporters or it's bad because
susan rice is associated with benghazi
and the republicans are going to seize
on that or whatever
the point is some group would find
something supposedly terrible about any
one of the people that was
being considered and the trump campaign
would find
something to seize on no question so we
can't really go by that in our analysis
now kamala harris's biggest liability
certainly is her role as attorney
general of california
executing the war on drugs and it was a
disaster it is the exact
opposite of what the democratic party
should be moving towards
republicans are going to hit her with it
and they're going to hit biden with it
they will say
we already know they will do it donald
trump has done
lots for black people he signed the
first step
act he's commuted to send the unfair
drug sentences of
you know list of people and meanwhile
biden is picking
kamala harris they're going to do it and
okay that'll be something that has to be
dealt with now
on the upsides to kamala harris
it depends on what's most important to
you but there's a few angles here
number one kamal is 55 years old
she's far younger than elizabeth warren
but most importantly she's way younger
than both
biden and trump and certainly brings an
energy and a dynamic to this race that
is completely missing
on the republican side and quite frankly
was missing uh with just joe biden on
the democratic side
as well if you believe that our leaders
should be younger than what we've been
seeing
lately um then this is a positive for
kamala harris number two
harris is a senator in california so if
biden wins and becomes vice president
that open senate seat in california will
be filled by democratic governor
gavin newsom until there's a special
election why does that matter
if it had been elizabeth warren who was
selected
republican governor of massachusetts
charlie baker
gets to pick a replacement and he picks
a republican and when you're looking at
a senate
in the fall where it's conceivable that
democrats could take control and if they
do it might only be by one
the last thing you want is to lose one
of those seats because elizabeth warren
leaves and then charlie baker picks a
republican so i think that that's
relevant now in terms of debating kamala
harris is going to absolutely destroy
mike pence
kamala harris a far better debater than
elizabeth warren
for sure kamala harris will make
mincemeat out of mike pence remember
this
incident with william barr thank you mr
chairman
attorney general barr has the president
or anyone at the white house ever asked
or suggested that you open an
investigation of anyone
um i wouldn't i wouldn't uh
yes or no
could you repeat that question i will
repeat it has the president or anyone at
the white house ever asked or suggested
that you open
an investigation of anyone yes or no
please sir
um the president or anybody else
seems you would remember something like
that and be able to tell us
yeah but i'm trying to grapple with the
word suggest i mean
there have been discussions of of
matters out there that
uh they have not asked me to open a
investigation but perhaps they've
suggested
i don't know i wouldn't say suggest
hinted i don't know
inferred you don't know
okay okay so that that's definitely a
plus
for kamala harris now let's step back
for a moment
a hearty debate about harris versus
whoever else
is great but we should not lose sight of
the reality
that were it kamala harris who had been
president instead of donald trump when
we were hit
with the pandemic uh this entire country
would be dramatically
better off today kamala harris at the
top level unlike donald trump can think
kamala harris unlike mike pence thinks
for
herself rather than simply being a brown
noser so i'm certainly not going to
allow myself
to be confused or to miss the forest for
the trees and forget that kamala harris
is someone who actually knows things who
can do things
who can function as an executive is
competent and intelligent whereas right
now
it's the blind leading the blind that's
what we have right now in the oval
office
she's not as progressive as i would like
okay and i know that there's debate over
this
trump said yesterday during his press
briefing that she's the
the most liberal senator um and of
course
uh now i would consider bernie sanders
to be takamala harris's left
elizabeth warren to be to kamala harris
is left it is true that a few years ago
kamala was ranked according to one
ranking
as the most left member of the senate
that's good
in my mind but certainly today when you
look at specific
uh positions on health care for example
okay she's not the most left
but i'm not going to lose sight of i'm
not going to lose the forest for the
trees now one other really interesting
thing to think about
joe biden choosing kamala harris is sort
of the antithesis
of how donald trump operates and i
tweeted about this yesterday and a lot
of people seem to react
positively generally i would say when
people come
at donald trump when people confront
trump
when people publicly say things about
trump
that they disagree with even people in
trump's own party
trump's reaction is to ostracize them
call them out publicly and cut them out
while assailing their character
because his skin is so thin
joe biden took his toughest critic
from the democratic primary and the
debates i mean
the biggest conflicts during the primary
were between joe biden and kamala harris
and
he put her next to him on the ticket
like him
or not like her or not this alone
is all the evidence i know i need to
know that this is a team that i would
choose over
trump pence any day these are adults
biden has been through so much in his
life
it's a joke to think that someone is
going to hurt his feelings by attacking
him
in a debate and he picked her to be
alongside him
on the ticket on the other hand you have
trump born with a silver spoon in his
mouth a complete narcissist and we've
seen how that has played out
with him as president and the answer is
not very well now some of the dumbest
takes
so far i've seen about this selection
one is questioning whether kamala harris
is
really black that's one that i'm seeing
over the last 12 16 hours on twitter
uh you know her dad is jamaican and
jamaicans are not african-american they
are
you know afro-caribbean or something
else altogether really dumb argument
okay
she's she's a woman of color and this
art she's not really african-american
come on guy that's the argument very
very dumb
and then number two i'm starting to see
the idea that
biden didn't choose her that the dnc
chose her or some shadow puppet masters
maybe jewish bankers in some cases chose
kamala harris because she's friendly to
banking
come on okay that we're not that's not
the direction we're going to go in here
policy analysis yes uh that that's
we're not going to go in that direction
last thoughts on this for now
the other reason that this choice is a
big deal and i'm not saying this is good
but it's
impactful is that the selection of
kamala harris
sort of sets the democratic party's
course
potentially for a decade or more bill
share wrote about this and you can find
his tweet about it
linking to his article he's bill share
on twitter
and bill share pointed out uh if vice
presidents
choose to run for president
at the end of their vice presidency
so to speak which could be if biden only
goes one term that could be in four
years or it could be in eight years
when vps run in the primary they
essentially always win they almost
always win
meaning that uh when joe biden picks
a vice president he is picking someone
who
would have available to them the
democratic party nomination
in four or eight years kamala harris
strikes me
in particular because of her young age
as someone who would be well suited to
after being vice president if she is run
for president
she is decidedly in the center-left
democratic establishment there's no
denying that we can argue about exactly
where she is on the spectrum of liberal
to to centrist
but she is not part of the populist
socialist
ish insurgency that we saw get behind
bernie sanders she's not in that wing
so if we get four or eight years of
biden
and then kamala if she wants the
nomination
whenever biden steps back or or is
is done if it's eight years she has it
available
we are talking about anywhere between
you know
eight and uh 16 years
of this type of democratic party a lot
of people are not
happy about that uh and that's something
we're going to be talking about more as
well but but this is a
like it or not this is a very
consequential selection
and a very consequential election as
well
august 23rd is the 15-year
anniversary of the david pakman show we
will be doing a
huge one-day membership special to
commemorate this
i invite you to get on our newsletter at
davidpakman.com you'll be notified
on the 23rd of something very very
special
something i don't think we've ever ever
seen before on the david pakman show
grab
a free newsletter subscription at
davidpakman.com
let me know your thoughts about kamala
harris via twitter
where you can find me at d pacman